este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
master works más sobre esto en un
momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
crea comunidad hace poco tiempo aquí en
visual político publicamos nuestro
particular ranking con algunas de las
ciudades más peligrosas del mundo algo
que siempre resulta complicado y que nos
obligó a escoger entre muchos candidatos
que quizás injustamente se quedaron
fuera que os voy a contar solo méxico
hubiera necesitado para ser justos un
vídeo entero y al norte de su frontera
también son muchas las ciudades que
merecen nuestra atención en aquel vídeo
mencionamos a sanluis una ciudad de la
que por cierto ya hemos hablado aquí en
visual político pero también podríamos
haberle hecho un hueco en el ranking a
ciudades como memphis detroit chicago o
quizás y sobre todo baltimore pero claro
con hoy vamos a dedicarle a baltimore
tan solo un minuto cuando una de las
mejores series dedicó cinco temporadas
completas por supuesto estamos hablando
de the wire seguro que muchos ya la
habéis visto y los que no toman nota
porque merece la pena la cuestión es que
el último capítulo de esta serie data
del año 2008 y desde entonces han pasado
mucho cosas tantas como para llegar a
montar una nueva producción el creador
de the wire regresa baltimore para la
nueva serie de hb jones the city amigos
amigas al igual que está pasando en el
conjunto de los eeuu la violencia se ha
disparado en baltimore
[Música]
solo en 2021 se registraron
338 homicidios en nueva york por ejemplo
hubo 485 la diferencia es que nueva york
tiene 15 veces más habitantes que
baltimore que no llega a los 600 mil
habitantes estamos hablando de una
ciudad que en los años 50 llegó a rondar
el millón de habitantes pero claro entre
los que mueren en los que se largan de
baltimore no paran de perder población
lo peor es que las malas noticias no
acaban ahí cada vez hay más casas
abandonadas más drogas en las calles y
menos futuro para sus jóvenes por eso la
pregunta es estamos acaso hablando de la
ciudad más decadente y violenta de los
eeuu que están haciendo las autoridades
de baltimore para cambiar la situación y
lo que resulta aún más importante están
hoy en visual político vamos a dar
respuestas a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
pero antes de pasar a la historia
dejadme que os hablé de masterworks
sabías que el mercado del arte está
valorado en casi 2 billones de dólares y
que deloitte estima que pueda crecer
casi otro millón más para 2026 seguro
que estás pensando a mí me cuentas no
tengo suelto mi cartera como para
comprarme un cuadro de picasso ahora
mismo pues ojo espera porque masterworks
permite a personas de cualquier parte
del mundo acceder a un mercado hasta
hace muy poco inaccesible para el común
de los mortales el arte pero es rentable
el arte contemporáneo bueno pues este
mercado consiguió mejores datos que el
propio s p500 incluyendo dividendos
apreciándose un nada desdeñable
164 por ciento en los últimos años de
1995 al 2021 el proceso masterworks
funciona así el equipo de análisis
estudia miles de datos para encontrar
obras financieramente atractivas con
potencial de revalorización
luego las compras por importes que van
desde el millón de dólares hasta los 30
millones y las titularizan mandando una
oferta pública a través de la secc por
último conservan la obra entre 3 y 10
años hasta que se vende si quieres
echarle un vistazo masterworks por ti
mismo te dejamos un link aquí abajo con
el que te puedes saltar la lista de
espera y crear una cuenta directamente
sin coste alguno y como siempre a la
hora de invertir mucho cuidado no existe
nada libre de riesgos
[Música]
ah
d guages
[Música]
estáis buscando casa pues estáis de
suerte con apenas unos 20 mil dólares
podéis comprar una en pleno baltimore
eso sí mucho ojo porque vuestro sueño
americano podría tornarse en una
pesadilla en cualquier momento las casas
adosadas de ladrillo del siglo 19 que
tanto abundan en el oeste de la ciudad
ofrecen en la actualidad un panorama
desolador muchas están abandonadas en su
día fueron el hogar soñado por miles de
inmigrantes europeos que llegaron a
baltimore durante su rápido crecimiento
industrial de finales del siglo 19 y
principios del 20 una época en la que la
ciudad más grande del estado de maryland
llegó a ser uno de los lugares más
prósperos de eeuu gracias a sus fábricas
su producción de acero y su puerto
[Música]
en el año 1950 a baltimore era la sexta
ciudad más grande de los eeuu sin
embargo un tercio de sus habitantes
emigró a medida que sus industrias
navieras y siderúrgicas fueron cerrando
luego la crisis de baltimore se agravó
aún más en los años 70 y 80 cuando la
heroína la cocaína y el crack comenzaron
a circular en abundancia por sus calles
de esta forma la adicción a las drogas
se extendió por los barrios más pobres
del oeste de la ciudad donde las leyes
raciales y unas políticas de vivienda
claramente racistas habían concentrado a
la población afroamericana la cual por
cierto supone alrededor de dos tercios
de todos los habitantes de la ciudad
el declive de baltimore durante las
últimas décadas es evidente a pesar de
haber sido una de las grandes ciudades
de eeuu y de contar con activos tan
valiosos como la prestigiosa universidad
johns hopkins su comercio portuario y
zonas tan atractivas como fells point lo
cierto es que los problemas no dejan de
multiplicarse
ah
en los años 90 otras grandes urbes
estadounidenses como nueva york tuvieron
éxito en su lucha contra el crimen
gracias a una combinación de prosperidad
económica un consumo más reducido de
alcohol y una mayor presión policial
mientras tanto baltimore se hundió cada
vez más y más las cifras son la prueba
del algodón ya sabéis el algodón no
engaña y aquí señalan que una octava
parte de la población de baltimore es
adicta a los narcóticos y que la ciudad
tiene la tasa de enfermedades venéreas
más alta del país así como una de las
más altas en cuanto a homicidios
[Música]
desde 1990 baltimore ha perdido más de
75 mil empleos industriales que no han
logrado ser compensados con otras
actividades en consecuencia una parte
importante de sus habitantes han quedado
atrapados en la pobreza en los barrios
más deprimidos de esta ciudad más de la
mitad de los adultos están desempleados
y la mitad de los adolescentes faltan
habitualmente a la escuela para que os
hagáis una idea un estudio realizado por
sociólogos de la universidad john
hopkins concluyó que sólo el 4% de los
niños de las zonas más deprimidas de
baltimore consigue terminar la
universidad el 4 por ciento
[Música]
son datos terribles que suponen un
enorme mazazo para los programas
sociales impulsados por el partido
demócrata y que visto lo visto no han
servido prácticamente de nada los
políticos demócratas han controlado la
alcaldía de baltimore desde el año
1967 hablamos de 55 años de gobierno ha
tenido de fracaso en fracaso en una
ciudad que fue conocida como la church
city la ciudad encantó
a comienzos del siglo por ejemplo muchas
esperanzas se depositaron en el alcalde
martin o'malley un joven abogado de
ascendencia irlandesa prometió reducir
la desigualdad y limpiar las calles con
una política de 'tolerancia cero' instó
a la policía a detener a los jóvenes que
actuaran de manera sospechosa y
registrarlos en busca de armas o drogas
y claro la policía como nado se tomó al
pie de la letra lo delató ganancia cero
y puso en su punto de mira a los que
cumplieran dos requisitos ser jóvenes y
ser negros como podéis imaginaros un
perfil que abunda mucho mal timo y
sabéis que se les fue de las manos
solo en 2005 la policía de baltimore
realizó 100 mil arrestos recordad que
hablamos de una ciudad de apenas unos
600.000 habitantes y como semejante
ritmo de detenciones era completamente
insostenible somalí tuvo que dar marcha
atrás en su enfoque policial de mano
dura pero el daño ya estaba hecho el
plan destruyó la confianza en la policía
de buena parte de la ciudad
el resultado fue un clima perfecto para
las pandillas la violencia y los
crímenes de todo tipo así que los que
han tenido oportunidad no lo han dudado
han salido corriendo de allí unos 16.000
edificios están designados oficialmente
como vacíos pero el número real podría
llegar a ser el doble calles enteras de
casas están tapiadas tan solo en los
últimos seis años se han demolido 5.000
casas para colmo la credibilidad de las
instituciones también ha hecho aguas
desde el año 2010 dos alcaldesas han
renunciado al estar involucradas en
escándalos de corrupción para que os
hagáis una idea en los últimos 12 años
baltimore ha tenido 6 alcaldes
diferentes y otros tantos comisarios
políticos un auténtico desastre que por
supuesto no ha pasado desapercibido
fijaos lo que en 2019 el propio
presidente dijo de esta ciudad
trump ataca a otro legislador
afroamericano y llama a baltimore un
desastre repugnante infestado de ratas y
roedores lo peor es que los políticos
demócratas no tuvieron con que rebatir
le baltimore se ha convertido en lo
parecido a un supermercado de la droga y
si las cosas y te estaba mal desde el
2015 se han puesto aún peor atentos
[Música]
fui a un city
todos sabéis quién es george flight pero
debéis saber que antes de georg floyd
estuvo freddy gray y otros tantos que
han sido víctimas de lo que podríamos
tildar como violencia racial de algunos
agentes de la policía en eeuu el caso es
que en 2015 freddy grade de 25 años que
había sido detenido por portar una
navaja falleció mientras estaba bajo
custodia de la policía de baltimore como
consecuencia de las lesiones que sufrió
en su columna mientras era trasladado en
una camioneta policial
al parecer era una práctica habitual de
la policía de baltimore esposar a los
detenidos no protegerles con el cinturón
de seguridad y conducir bruscamente para
que fueran lo más parecido a una pelota
en un maletero damos golpes por todos
los lados el caso es que las protestas
masivas y los disturbios se extendieron
por toda la ciudad fue algo así como un
punto de no retorno a raíz de este
suceso los disturbios aumentaron en un
50% y ahora podemos encontrarnos con
noticias como este últimos superan los
300 homicidios por séptimo año
consecutivo ahora bien un momento si
baltimore es una ciudad donde de vez en
cuando la policía mata a algún negro
pero sobre todo baltimore es una ciudad
donde prácticamente todos los días un
joven negro es asesinado por otro joven
negro algo de lo que por cierto muchos
incluida una investigación del propio
gobierno federal parecen culpar a la
propia policía el prejuicio racial es
generalizado entre la policía de
baltimore según señala el departamento
de justicia como va un cuerpo de policía
para garantizar la seguridad si nadie
confía en él la mayoría de los
habitantes de la ciudad lo ven como una
institución hostil y se niegan a
colaborar con ella esto es un problema
los episodios de brutalidad policial
hacen mucho más improbable que los
residentes de los vecindarios negros
acudan a la policía para denunciar
delitos y cooperar con las
investigaciones y la misma desconfianza
se extiende sobre los órganos judiciales
muy relacionados lógicamente con la
propia policía y eso no es todo para
colmo una parte del cuerpo de policía se
dedicó durante años a extorsionar a
personas inocentes y a robar a
traficantes de droga para quedarse con
su negocio digamos que se creyeron los
amos de la ciudad haciendo justicia la
ciudad de baltimore paga 525 mil dólares
a una víctima que dice que policías
corruptos lo enviaron a prisión por
error uno más de los 14 millones de
dólares en acuerdos al final la crisis
económica la pérdida de empleos los
narcóticos y la corrupción de la
política alimentaron el desastre pero
espera un momento porque aún hay más
hoy día la violencia se ve alimentada
por un enemigo que va más allá de las
fronteras de baltimore hablamos del
centa nilo un opiáceo sintético muy
potente que ha sustituido a la heroína
es una locura tan solo en el 2021 más de
100 mil 100.000 personas fallecieron en
eeuu por sobredosis la situación es tan
grave que en su último discurso sobre el
estado de la unión el propio presidente
bailén hizo de esto toda una prioridad
nacional
showmatch
whittingdale
[Aplausos]
sí
el caso es que en 2007 la sobredosis de
opiáceos se cobraron la vida de 256
habitantes de baltimore en su mayor
parte por culpa de la heroína para 2018
ese número sabía más que triplicado a
814 muertes por el fentanilo baltimore
tiene la tasa de mortalidad por opiáceos
más alta de todas las ciudades
estadounidenses y ahora tiene un plan
para reducir la otra cosa es que el plan
sea bueno atentos
adictos a las drogas y a los impuestos
a
el alcalde de baltimore brandon scott
del partido demócrata quiere enfrentarse
a este boom de sobredosis abriendo
sitios de consumo seguro se trata de
lugares donde las personas acuden a
consumir narcóticos allí están bajo la
supervisión de personal médico que puede
intervenir de forma rápida en caso de
sobredosis para evitarles la muerte
imaginaos lo mal que están las cosas
para que estos planes se pongan sobre la
mesa no es una idea original pero si es
una idea que topo recientemente con la
oposición de la administración trump que
tumbó en los tribunales federales una
propuesta similar de la ciudad de
filadelfia las leyes vigentes a nivel
federal en los eeuu señalan que no están
permitidos los sitios públicos abiertos
para el consumo de drogas pero ahora las
cosas podrían cambiar con byd en el
departamento de justicia señala que
puede permitir sitio de inyección
seguros los miembros del partido
demócrata que defienden estos lugares
esgrimen que tratar de salvar la vida de
estas personas está por encima de
cualquier otra consideración las buenas
intenciones no se cuestionan pero de
verdad que lo mejor que se puede hacer
por las personas adictas es abrir un
lugar al que pueden acudir a meterse de
todo o casi a todo una pregunta difícil
y cuanto menos polémica y sobre todo no
parece que pueda contribuir a mejorar
las cosas en baltimore
[Música]
hablando de futuro fijaos en esta
noticia un estudio encuentra que una
familia de baltimore con ingresos
promedio paga el 14,1 por ciento de sus
ingresos anuales en impuestos locales y
estatales esto supone que en baltimore
pagan un 50% más de impuestos locales
que la media de las grandes ciudades de
eeuu
[Música]
esta ciudad amigos tiene un régimen
fiscal con una progresividad muy
agresiva y en total la ciudad ocupa el
cuarto puesto entre las grandes urbes
estadounidenses con la carga fiscal más
elevada algo así como el sueño dorado de
muchos demócratas del ala de bernie
sanders
esta elevada carga fiscal tiene una
explicación como habéis visto la ciudad
viene perdiendo población desde 1950
entonces que han hecho los políticos del
partido demócrata que gestionan
baltimore desde
1967 pues ni más ni menos que subir los
impuestos para tratar de mantener los
ingresos de la ciudad ante la fuga de
contribuyentes así que a un problema
generalizado de violencia narcóticos y
falta de oportunidades laborales se suma
el tener los impuestos más altos del
país y la pregunta es quién en su sano
juicio va a querer mudarse a baltimore
quien negocio puede prosperar en
semejantes circunstancias por supuesto
los altos impuestos expulsan a más
profesionales y reducen la renta de las
familias lo que dificulta que las
empresas crezcan esto reduce la oferta
de empleo y agrava el problema con la
violencia y los narcóticos es algo así
como una espiral de destrucción y si
seguro que alguno de vosotros está
pensando pero alberto habrá que sostener
los servicios públicos pues sabéis que
fijaos
[Música]
y algunas investigaciones apuntan a que
el 77 por ciento de los estudiantes de
secundaria en baltimore tienen la
capacidad y la comprensión lectora
propia de la escuela primaria un total
desastre
[Música]
ah
la cuestión es quién demonios va a
querer mudarse a baltimore amigos amigas
esta ciudad tiene que darle al botón de
reset y empezar prácticamente desde cero
no estaría mal que en ese camino copian
las políticas económicas de estados como
texas o florida si las cosas no cambian
la que una vez fue una de las grandes
ciudades del país terminará en escombros
si algo está claro es que el plan
demócrata en baltimore no ha funcionado
absolutamente nada pero dicho esto te
paso alternativo que solución pondría
sobre la mesa para arreglar los
problemas de esta ciudad déjanos por
aquí abajo vuestros comentarios y
abramos debate ahora si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y suscribir os aviso al
político un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]